[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
produire de l'électricité avec du vent
ou du soleil aujourd'hui
et bien c'est devenu moins cher dans la
plupart des cas qu'avec des énergies
conventionnelles polluantes
en fait les énergies renouvelables sont
non seulement plus écologique
mais elles sont aussi devenus moins cher
et donc on pourrait se demander pourquoi
pourquoi on les développe pas plus
rapidement et bien tout simplement parce
que elles sont intermittentes
ça veut dire que elles produisent elles
ne produisent pas de manière constante
et très souvent quand on implante des
éoliennes quelque part ou des panneaux
photovoltaïques
eh bien on a des ailes à des centrales à
gaz ou des centrales à fuel pas très
loin on va allumer pour produire de
l'électricité
quand il ya plus de vent ont plus de
soleil et du coup il ya beaucoup de gens
qui considèrent que de ce fait là les
énergies renouvelables ne sont pas verte
du tout il ya côté de ça il ya d'autres
personnes qui disent que ben non pas du
tout il suffit de stocker l'énergie
le problème c'est que stocker de
l'énergie ça coûte extrêmement cher
aujourd'hui une période sans soleil ça
dure à peu près 12 heures on appelle ça
la nuit et des périodes sans vent ça
peut durer encore plus longtemps
et bien si on voulait stockée dans des
batteries la production d'électricité
d'un pays comme la france pendant 12
heures
il faudrait investir 300 milliards
d'euros
c'est à peu près cinq fois le budget de
l'éducation nationale
il faudrait renouveler cet
investissement tous les dix ans parce
que c'est aujourd'hui la durée de vie
des batteries
alors il existe d'autres façons de
stocker l'énergie
vous êtes peut-être entendu parler de
l'hydrogène ou bien de l'air comprimé
elle a encore beaucoup d'autres
mais toutes ces solutions sont encore
plus cher sauf une
ce sont les stations de pompage
turbinage on les appelle aussi les
stations de transfert d'énergie par
pompage
en fait ce sont des centrales
hydroélectriques qui sont capables de
fonctionner dans les deux sens et quand
on a un surplus d'électricité sur le
réseau électrique
on va pouvoir l'utiliser pour pomper de
l'eau d'un réservoir aval vers un
réservoir amont et ça va permettre de
transformer cette énergie électrique en
énergie potentielle et on va ensuite
pouvoir la réutiliser
quand il ya une pénurie d'électricité
sur le réseau ça va fonctionner dans le
sens inverse le réservoir hamon va se
vider dans la conduite qui ait servi à
le remplir
il va remplir le réservoir aval en
actionnant une turbine hydroélectrique
alors il ya deux problèmes à cette
solution
tout d'abord ce n'est pas beaucoup moins
cher qu'une batterie et puis on ne peut
implanter ce type de système que dans
certaines zones montagneuses
parce qu'il faut que les les deux
réservoirs d'eau qui les constituent
soit situé non seulement à des altitudes
très différentes pour maximiser le
stockage d'énergie mais aussi qu'ils ne
soient pas trop éloignés l'un de l'autre
parce que sinon eh bien on va augmenter
exponentiellement le coût de la conduite
qui les relie alors ce système là il en
existe un certain nombre dans le monde
déjà les stations étaient évidemment
implantées dans les zones qui sont
économiquement les plus intéressantes et
donc les futures implantations vont se
faire dans des endroits où qui font que
les coûts de ce système vont
son jouet a augmenté en permanence voilà
donc qu'il s'agisse de batterie ou de
stations de pompage turbinage on peut
considérer que le stockage d'énergie
c'est avant tout un problème économique
et par voie de conséquence ça freine
considérablement la dynamique de
transition énergétique
alors comme ingénieur j'ai eu l'occasion
de travailler pendant une dizaine
d'années dans l'industrie automobile et
sur des fonctions de rationalisation et
de réduction des coûts et un jour je me
suis dit que s'il était possible de
réduire les coûts dans un domaine qui
est mûr depuis des dizaines d'années on
arrive encore à réduire les coûts
aujourd'hui dans ce domaine
il va être possible aussi de réduire les
coûts dans le domaine du stockage
d'énergie pour le réseau électrique
sachant que c'est une problématique qui
est beaucoup plus récente et c'est comme
ça que j'ai imaginé deux façons de
réduire très fortement le coût du
stockage d'énergie que je vais vous
présenter alors la première solution
on va quitter les zones de montagne on
va aller en mer parce qu'en mer on a des
dénivelés très important entre le fond
de la mer et la surface la profondeur
moyenne des maires des environs près de
4000 mètres et on va imaginer une très
grosse masse en béton qu'on va poser au
fond de l'eau et puis on va prendre une
barge en surface donc avec un treuil
électrique et avec un long câble
on va venir s'accrocher à la masse et on
va la remontée sur 4000 mètres de
dénivelé en faisant ça le treuil va
transformer l'énergie électrique en
énergie potentielle et bien sûr 4000
mètres de dénivelé il est possible de
stocker autant d'énergie dans un kilo de
béton que dans un demi-kilo de batterie
or un kilo de béton ça coûte 100 fois
moins cher qu'un demi kg de batteries
donc ça vous donne une idée des
économies énormes qu'on peut faire comme
ça il fallait ensuite trouver une
solution qui permette
d'exploiter ce principe pour le réseau
électrique
et bien c'est tout simple il suffit de
relier la barge au réseau électrique
avec un câble sous marin le même type de
câble qu'on utilise pour les éoliennes
offshore
et donc quand on a un surplus
d'électricité sur le réseau
eh bien il va être injecté dans le câble
électrique vers la barge qui va remonter
des masses en béton une à une depuis le
fond de la mer jusqu'à la surface
et ensuite quand il ya une pénurie
d'électricité
ça va fonctionner en sens inverse les
masses vont être redescendu une à une et
elles vont tirer sur le treuil qui va
fonctionner en mode générateurs
électriques un petit peu comme une
dynamo si vous voulez alors il faut
utiliser pour maximiser la capacité de
stockage on va utiliser plusieurs
dizaines de masse pour un seul treuil
ça permet d'augmenter la capacité sans
augmenter le coût du treuil et de la
barge et pour ça il faut trouver une
solution pour les maintenir en surface
quand on les stocke en hauteur on peut
par exemple les accrocher à des
flotteurs et pour éviter que ces
flotteurs ne partent à la dérive quand
il ya une tempête
eh bien on va ancrer ses flotteurs avec
des longs câbles d'ancrage un petit peu
comme on en trouve pour les plateformes
certaines plates formes pétrolières et
en mer on doit généralement dimensionné
quand on construit un bateau une
plateforme n'importe quoi il faut tenir
compte des conditions exceptionnelles ce
qui arrive une fois tous les 50 ans ou
tous les cent ans
et pour que ça résiste à des tempêtes
exceptionnelles il faut des câbles en
acier qui soit très épais et en plus ils
doivent être très long parce qu'on est
sur des profondeurs très importante et
donc on va voir des câbles qui vont être
très coûteux et tout le bénéfice qu'on
va tirer de ces masses en béton qui un
matériau peu cher qui stocke beaucoup
sur des dénivelés importants
on va le perdre avec des câbles qui sont
trop coûteux et bien j'ai inventé et
breveté plusieurs solutions techniques
qui permettent de faire en sorte que ces
flotteurs ne soit pas situé en surface
exposée au vent et aux vagues mais
plusieurs dizaines de mètres
en dessous de l'eau en dessous de la
surface en permanence alors une des
façons de faire c'est de rassembler tous
ses flotteurs sur un support unique et
que ce support unique soit lui même
rattaché ancré au fond de l'eau avec
quelques câbles d'ancrage alors de me
dire oui mais justement les câbles
d'ancrage c'est cher sauf qu'ici on va
adapter la capacité flottante de la
structure en fonction du nombre de
masques on va y accrocher donc chaque
fois qu'on va raccrocher une masse on va
injecter de l'air dans un flotteur qui
va devenir flottant est de telle sorte
qu'on n'aura jamais plus que
l'équivalent d'une masse en force de
tension dans le câble et ça permet de
réduire très fortement les coûts de ce
composant alors il ya une petite
consommation d'énergie quand on fait ça
qu'il faut comprimés de l'air mais on
peut démontrer que elle pèse à peu près
1 % de la capacité totale qu'on peut
accumuler sur des dénivelés de 4000 m je
connais à peu près à 40 mètres pour les
flotteurs alors le principal intérêt de
cette solution il est au niveau du coût
d'investissement
si on additionne le coût de tous les
composants donc le béton a vu que ça
faisait à peu près 100 fois moins cher
qu'une batterie et qu'on rajoute les
câbles et quand même quelques câbles
d'ancrage des flotteurs barges et puis
surtout si on prend aussi en compte le
coût du câble sous-marin qui
transportent l'électricité même sur des
distances de plus de 100 km eh bien on
arrive à un coût total d'investissement
qui est environ dix fois plus faible 10
fois plus faible que les meilleures
batteries de actuelle ça peut sembler un
peu difficile à croire mais ça peut se
vérifier s est facilement parce que ces
composants en fait on on les utilise
déjà dans un environnement maritime pour
d'autres applications évidemment en
général c'est dans l'industrie
pétrolière offshore
et donc on connaît très bien leur coup
et on sait également qu'elle est leur
durée de vie
donc voilà une solution très
intéressante sur le plan économique
qui donc doit être implantées en mer
pourraient être liés à des systèmes
éoliens solaires terrestre et puis aussi
aux consommateurs sur terre quand on est
dans des sur un réseau électrique qui
est située à quelques centaines de
kilomètres de la côte
les goûts sont tout à fait acceptable
mais des congrès sur des distances
beaucoup plus importante
quelques milliers de kilomètres c'est le
cas par exemple de l'amérique du nord du
centre de l'amérique du nord ou du
centre de l'asie alors cette solution
n'est plus si intéressante d'un point de
vue économique parce qu'il est le coût
du transport d'électricité qui devient
trop élevé et donc pour ces cas de
figure là j'ai imaginé une autre façon
de réduire le coût du stockage d'énergie
donc là on va quitter la mer et on va
revenir sur terre et en valais dans des
zones toute plate on a vu que les
stations de pompage turbinage on ne peut
les mettre que dans des zones
montagneuses
donc là on va faire exprès d'aller dans
des zones toutes plates et on va creuser
un grand trou de forme conique un petit
peu comme les grandes mines à ciel
ouvert où les grandes carrières forme
conique pour éviter les glissements de
terrain on va prendre une pente plutôt
prudente et avec toute la roche qu'on va
excavées on va ériger un barrage en
remblais circulaire juste à côté
et comme ça on va fabriquer deux
réservoirs qu'on pourra remplir d'eau
qui seront pas à la même altitude et qui
seront pas trop éloignés l'un de l'autre
ça permet de résoudre le principal
problème du pompage turbinage on peut
donc en faire n'importe où y compris
dans des zones toutes plates pour
l'enfer en picardie par exemple
évidemment un système si simple on se
dit que
si c'était en plus de sa économique ça
serait trop beau et de fait quand on
regarde ce que ça coûte avec dépit
calcul d'ordre de grandeur sur un cas
générique on tombe sur un coût
d'investissement qui à peu près deux
fois plus élevée que des batteries pour
des fausses 200 mètres de profondeur
mais regardons ce qui se passe si on
augmente la taille du dispositif on va
doubler les dimensions si on double la
profondeur la largeur et la longueur de
la fosse ainsi que le barrage on va
multiplier les volumes par huit on va
pouvoir stocker huit fois plus d'eau va
falloir extraire huit fois plus de roche
et on va aussi devoir payer 8 fois plus
cher par contre la capacité de stockage
d'énergie
elle dépend du volume d'eau mais elle
dépend également du dénivelé qui aura
été multiplié par deux
donc la capacité de stockage d'énergie
aurait été multiplié par 16 alors que le
kun aura été multipliée par huit
on a un phénomène d'économies d'échelle
en augmentant la taille la capacité de
stockage augmenté plus vite que le coût
et la question n'est plus combien trop
cher c'est de stocker l'énergie la
question ça devient quelle taille ça
doit avoir pour que ça soit
économiquement intéressant et bien si on
creusait une fosse de la tour eiffel
s'est mise à l'échelle 1 le but c'est de
pas se creuser un trou à paris puis
d'ensevelir la moitié des
arrondissements sous sous 100 mètres de
roche si on creuse un trou de 400 mètres
de profondeur eh bien on peut atteindre
un coût d'investissement qui est deux
fois plus faible que celui des batteries
et en plus on a une durée de vie qui est
plus importante
donc en coût total actualisé on arrive à
quelque chose qui est cinq à six fois
plus avantageux économiquement
par contre ça suppose de stocker des
très grandes quantités d'énergie sur un
seul site
on parle de 50 gigawatt heure mais c'est
tout à fait réaliste pour reprendre
l'exemple de la france avec les 12
heures dans ce cas là il faudrait
construire une vingtaine de sites de
cette taille est pour
votre info le mix énergétique actuelle
qui est un mix majoritairement nucléaire
et bien les 62 réacteurs nucléaires ils
sont concentrées sur une vingtaine de
sites
donc en termes de concentration de
puissance ce n'est pas un problème
après pour creuser des fosses de 400
mètres on peut se dire que c'est trop
grand c'est utopique
pas du tout les plus grandes mines à
ciel ouvert du monde
elles sont deux fois plus profondes et
sont dix fois plus volumineuse les plus
haut barrage du monde en remblais ils
sont trois fois plus haut et puis la
surface qui sera occupé par un système
comme ça on parle de au total cinq
kilomètres carrés donc si on voulait
construire une vingtaine de sites dans
un pays comme la france donc il faudrait
occupé une surface qui serait 1000 fois
plus faible plus de mille fois plus
faible que la surface agricole
donc ça serait négligeable en
comparaison de l'enjeu environnemental
et économique que ça représente
alors j'ai pris l'exemple de la france
parce que c'est plus parlant pour nous
tous mais bon une telle solution pour la
france qui est un pays quand même
maritime
c'est quand même la solution des masses
en béton en mer qui reste de loin la
plus économique
enfin la plus avantageuse mais voilà à
quoi pourrait ressembler le mix
énergétique du futur du moins sur sa
composante stockage d'énergie on aurait
à peu près trois quarts du stockage avec
des solutions maritime
et puis le reste avec des solutions plus
traditionnel mais sur des systèmes de
très grande dimension à économies
d'échelle alors on me demande parfois
comment il se fait que des solutions qui
sont si simples et surtout très
économiques ne sont pas développées
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que j'ai
commencé à divulguer ses idées il y à
peu près quatre ans je les ai présenté
d'abord aux ministères de l'énergie et
de l'industrie dans plusieurs pays en
europe et également à quelques grands
groupes énergétiques généralistes
également en europe
tout simplement parce que il s'agit d'un
enjeu environnemental et économique
et puis aussi il ya des enjeux de
création d'emplois qui est très
important
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer de
nombreux experts dans les différentes
disciplines qui sont concernés par ces
systèmes et jusqu'à présent personne n'a
remis en cause les hypothèses
économiques
alors j'ai pris des hypothèses qui sont
aussi très prudente mais est pareil pas
de pas de remise en cause de la
faisabilité et pourtant j'ai constaté
maintenant avec un peu de recul qui a
une certaine frilosité de la part des
grands acteurs du secteur de l'énergie à
promouvoir des systèmes de stockage qui
soit vraiment low cost et qui permette
enfin de concurrencer les les backup
thermique fossiles qu'on développe
aujourd'hui pour être combiné avec des
nouvelles énergies renouvelables et
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai trouvé
que ce serait une bonne chose de
commencer à communiquer auprès d'un
public plus large et notamment via une
conférence tedx merci pour votre
attention
[Applaudissements]